yeah Hans I don't want to be too
annoying but I really want to just ask
uh about the move Knight a G5 because it
looked like you were about to capture
that PA and make that move and then you
switched what was the reason uh what was
the decision that like changed it from
one second to the other I just thought
that I should
um I I obviously understood that I had a
much better position um I thought that
Queen F5 was a risk-free way to play on
so uh maybe I'm getting old and uh
afraid so I have to go back to my uh uh
impulsive instincts of playing for wi at
all cost so it's it's hard to balance
that um um because you know uh ambition
uh is a double-edged sword um but uh
okay I had two seconds on the clock it
was a split second decision um usually
uh you try to keep things simple um but
at least I'm very happy with how I
played